[Música]
gracias hola hola qué tal
imagino que aquí voy hogar y no puedo
salir de aquí bueno me da mucho gusto
estar aquí en tepic con todos ustedes en
esta en esta conferencia es un honor
siempre está en este tipo de
conversaciones porque sé que número uno
ahí en el público entre ustedes hay
gente muy muy valiosa y es un honor
compartir con ustedes y además porque
han pasado por este sanar gente también
muy muy especial para mí es un verdadero
honor estar acá y el tema cuando me
dijeron estás esta plática está ted se
va a tratar tratar de la resiliencia que
son que es lo que más me ha hecho crecer
me puse a pensar que eso que me has me
ha ayudado a crear resiliencia
resistencia a levantarme una y otra vez
en mi vida y finalmente la lección que
estoy aprendiendo hoy más que nunca en
mi vida es el tema de valorar y aprender
a ver al dolor como un gran maestro
a lo mejor de este chico conocí el dolor
desde una edad muy temprana a través de
a través de mi mamá porque ella se
divorció dos veces yo soy hijo fui fue
el segundo matrimonio de ella cuando se
casó con mi papá que era un hombre muy
brillante muy inteligente él tenía la
enfermedad del alcoholismo en aquellos
tiempos la gente se casaba y luego
descubrían que eran alcohólicos no no
era como hoy que en instagram te puedes
dar cuenta que alguien es alcohólico
desde las insta a story no tienes que
casarte para descubrirlo pero en esos
tiempos no era así te casabas un poco a
ciegas y ya o sorpresa y pues el
alcohólico y era golpeador
y se la pasaba casi siempre tomado o
borracho fue la razón por la que mi mamá
se separó de mi papá entonces yo lo que
aprendí desde niño fueron dos cosas muy
dolorosas una que a mi mamá el ser
humano más sagrado en mi vida el ser
humano que me dio la vida la mujer que
me inspiraba la mujer que me cuidaba la
mujer que yo amaba con todo mi corazón
había pasado por cosas muy duras como
golpes y como como abuso verbal abuso
psicológico y que había tenido que
dejarlo y que había y que había pasado
ya por dos divorcios en to you desde
niño a mí me dolía me dolía mucho en mi
corazón este tema y yo me acuerdo que le
decía estaban nos ponían de niños
aquella canción de los tres cochinitos
de greens se acuerdan si los que acaban
de nacer yo creo que no conocían a
cri-cri no creo que tenga cuenta roba
cri crí en instagram
pero hay una canción se acuerdan de los
tres cochinitos y te dice que el más
grande era era trabajador y el otro era
empresario pero hablaba del tercer
cochinito y decía el tercer cochinito
conocía el más pequeño
es un cochinito lindín cortés con el
sueño de ser porque los tres cochinitos
soñaban se acuerdan el tercer cochinito
soñaba para trabajar y ayudar a su pobre
nómada ya mí me dolía tanto y cuando
escuché esa canción yo me acuerdo que le
dije y se lo repetí muchas veces pensaba
un mes que yo soy el tercer cochinito yo
voy a crecer y voy a trabajar para
ayudarte y sacarte adelante y desde muy
niño tenían 12 34 años yo sé como se me
ocurrió echarme esa misión pero se me
ocurrió simplemente lo sabía y así era y
desde niño crecí con ese dolor tan
grande de verla sufrir de verla trabajar
de ver como una mujer si hoy en día las
mujeres no tienen igualdad social en
nuestro país en el mundo todavía
imagínense en el méxico de 1970 que fue
cuando yo vine a este a este mundo me
dolía ver la discriminación incluso
dentro de la familia incluso verla con
sus hermanos o sea comerla en la familia
como la discriminada por ser mujer y por
ser separada y ver como la trataban a
veces hay gorda tú que sabes le desean
suceder sus propios hermanos
me hervía el coraje y abajo del coraje
había dolor y abajo del dolor habían
unas ganas de crecer y ayudarás a
sacarla adelante
el otro dolor con el que crecí también
fue justamente la ausencia de mi papá no
porque dije bueno éste nunca le importe
nunca se apareció nunca nunca ayudó
nunca llamó a ver cómo estaban
simplemente estuvo estuvo ausente y por
más que yo de niño me quise lavar el
coco lavarme la cabeza diciendo no me
hace falta nada a mi mamá es mi papá y
mi mamá en el fondo y en la realidad si
te hace falta obviamente te hace falta
no tener el ejemplo de un hombre fuerte
de tu me pongo a pensar cuántos errores
cometió en mi carrera con el dinero
queriendo ser empresario en la parte
musical estás cosas con tus errores
cometido por falta de un hombre madura
en la casa que me hubiera dicho no no no
no hagas eso este contrato yo lo firmé
eso vamos a revisar estas cosas que yo
sé y hoy que aconsejo a mis sobrinos oa
gente más joven y ahora de grandes como
más me di cuenta que dije guau cuántas
cosas hice yo solo cuántos errores
cometí
que no debería haber cometido
y esos son dolores muy grandes con los
que con los que crecí y cuando hice la
maestría en psicología espiritual en la
universidad de santa mónica en los
ángeles quizás lo más valioso que
aprendí fue justamente que la forma en
que yo veía al dolor era la forma en que
me programaron y nos programan
normalmente en la escuela en la iglesia
en la familia para relacionarnos con el
dolor nos dicen que la felicidad o que
nos todos os han dicho eso no que tu
objetivo es en la vida es ser feliz no
levantar la mano que el quien ha oído
que el objetivo en la vida es ser feliz
ok perfecto a levante hermano quien no
lo oído y lo acabo de escuchar por
primera vez en su vida
entonces estudiando psicología
espiritual nos decía no sean nuestros
maestros ronnie y mary jane doctores en
psicología autores de varios libros
amigos de obra en fin son son dos
maestros muy muy importantes muy muy
queridos y muy respetados en el mundo de
la psicología en eeuu
decían el formato de felicidad que nos
enseñan es aumentar el número de
experiencias positivas que tenemos en la
vida y evitar a toda costa el número de
experiencias negativas que tenemos en la
vida eso es la felicidad en la fórmula
del mundo físico en la fórmula humana
más experiencias positivas más felicidad
más experiencias negativas menos
felicidad es decir si tengo una casa soy
feliz
sin renton pues no soy tan feliz si
tengo un auto soy feliz
si ando en camiones no soy tan feliz si
estoy sin salud en mi cuerpo y el de mi
familia y la gente a la que amo soy más
feliz si hay no hay salud en la familia
y en mi cuerpo soy menos feliz y al paz
a eso le agregamos el tema de ser
afortunado o desafortunado y le
agregamos el tema de gracias diosito
porque me regalaste esta esta salud del
dinero la casa el auto y diosito no se
que estoy haciendo porque me castiga si
no tengo que no nos empezamos a
calificar con base en experiencias
positivas entre comillas entre comillas
y descalificar si tenemos experiencias
negativas incluso yo mismo me di cuenta
que yo me amaba más cuando estaba
haciendo teniendo resultados positivos y
me amaba menos o me odiaba o incluso yo
solito me insultaba como si fuera mi
peor enemigo cuando no tenía éxito
cuando no tenía dinero cuando cuando me
equivocaba cuando estaba pasado de peso
entonces en nuestros maestros nos
dijeron a info quizás de lo más valioso
que me cambió la vida y nos decían algo
que repito siempre ahora en conferencias
y talleres la verdadera felicidad la
felicidad a nivel
virtual no se mide por el número de
experiencias positivas o negativas
porque en el punto de vista espiritual
nada es positivo ni es negativo nada es
bueno ni es malo las cosas simplemente
son son lo que son y todo lo que se nos
presenta en el mundo físico son
experiencias que el universo que dios
nos regala con todo su amor para poder
experimentar lo que tenemos que
experimentar para poder desarrollarnos
porque la escuela es como la de la vida
es como una escuela y venimos con ese
objetivo con el objetivo de crecer de
evolucionar de aprender y aprender qué
bueno de aprender que mi verdadera
esencia que tu verdadera esencia es el
amor porque dios es amor y cuando nos
hablan de que estamos hechos de imagen y
semejanza de dios no se refieren
específicamente a que tengamos dos ojos
una nariz y pelo sino más bien a que la
esencia de dios es el amor nuestra
esencia mi esencia la esencia de cada
uno de nosotros es el amor y a veces las
experiencias que se presentan pueden ser
agradables eso sí o desagradables son un
simple pretexto para experimentar lo
necesario como ir a la escuela y me
inscribo una materia y me toque
experimentar ciertas cosas en mí en mi
escuela para recordar quién soy para
aprender quién soy para despertar y
tomar conciencia de quién soy y entonces
en una ocasión estamos haciendo una
meditación en la escuela donde teníamos
que cerrar nuestros ojos bajaban las
luces ponían música así muy suavecita
muy hermosa y mary la maestra
nos pedía que fuéramos hacia adentro el
ejercicio tenía que ver con el
agradecimiento a nuestro niño interior
alguna vez ustedes han tenido contacto
levante la mano quien ha tenido contacto
con su niño interior no levante la mano
quien sí perdón quien se ha tenido
contacto levante la mano quien no
levante la mano quien va a tener aquella
dijeron que existía tienen un niño
interior si tienes un niño interior y te
conviene estar en contacto te decimos
una meditación y nos pedían que nos
viéramos a los ojos que nos visualizamos
como cuando teníamos tres años y que a
partir de ahí nos expresáramos el
agradecimiento por el valor por los
sueños por la determinación para llegar
a donde estábamos porque ese niño entero
al final del día sigue viviendo contigo
sigue existiendo dentro de ti y cuando
estaba viendo a mi niño interior estaba
un bonito el ejercicio de repente algo
mágico sucedió y fue que en vez de verme
a mí de repente vi a mi papá pues yo no
crecí con mi papá ni tuvo una relación
con europa y nunca hablaba de mi papá
pues simplemente no existía y yo pensaba
yo no lo odio ni le tengo coraje
simplemente no es nada pero la verdad es
que si se lo tenía le tenía un rencor
así medio pasivo de nunca estuviste en
mi vida un golpe hasta en mi mamá
me explico era él era como el centro de
todo lo malo en mi vida no así lo
juzgaba yo a él y en ese momento
a mi papá pero no lo vi como un adulto
y lo vi como un niño en vez de verme a
mí como niño lo biel como niño y en ese
preciso instante todos los juicios que
yo tenía de él
desaparecieron y me permitieron verlo
con otros ojos con los ojos del amor con
los ojos del corazón y me acuerdo que lo
vi a los ojos y le dije
qué cosas habrás vivido de niño que te
llevaron a ser alcohólico qué violencia
habrás aprendido en tu casa que te
llevaron a ser un hombre violento qué
cosas tan duras habrás visto que yo no
vi y yo no viví porque yo no crecí con
él entonces yo no vi violencia familiar
él sí creció con violencia familiar mi
abuelo también el alcohólico y mi abuelo
también golpeaba a la abuela y él creció
viendo eso y entonces empecé a recordar
que mi mamá me decía que él también
amaba a su mamá con todo su corazón y
kate cosas que yo sabía pero no
recordaba y lo vi dije guau tú creciste
viendo cómo golpeaban a tu mamita
yo no crecía así y por eso probablemente
pero lo único que sabía hacer y
repetiste la historia y sentir compasión
y amor por él y sentí un descanso tan
grande en mi corazón
sentí que descanse de algo que ni
siquiera sabía que traía conmigo y me
acuerdo que no solamente lo vi con
compasión y con amor y me sentí y le di
un abrazo me acuerdo que me habrás ellos
solo pensando que lo abrazaba él y
cuando lograse
otra cosa aparece en mi mente y le dije
guau
si tú no hubieras estado ausente si tú
no hubiera sido quién fuiste yo no sería
quién soy
y si tú no te hubieras ido y tú no
hubieras hecho las cosas que me dolieron
tanto de niño que nunca hubiera tenido
la oportunidad de ser ese tercer
cochinito que llegué a hacer porque si
lo hice a los 18 años logré mantener a
mi mamá sacarla de trabajar se convirtió
como mi hija hice todos mis sueños
mi gran sueño era ayudar a mi mamá y lo
hice y le dije si tú hubieras estado
presente como yo creía que era lo
correcto y lo normal yo nunca hubiera
tenido la oportunidad de manifestar mi
corazón manifestar mi amor aparte a lo
mejor no hubiera tenido la carrera que
tengo porque todo lo hice con la ilusión
de sacar adelante mi mamá ese coraje que
me dio que no estuvieras fue lo que me
construyó y de repente así de la nada
como si fuera una película como magia
sentí por primera vez en mi vida
gratitud por él y le pude decir gracias
por haber sido alcohólico gracias por
todo lo que hiciste y lo hiciste gracias
por tu ausencia porque si hubiera tenido
el lugar perfecto no sería quién soy y
la verdad estoy muy a gusto y muy feliz
quién soy dije papá gracias yo sé que no
fue agradable ni para ti ni para mí ni
para mi mamá yo sé que tú no hubieras
querido esto que el niño quiere crecer y
convertirse en un alcohólico golpeador
nadie qué niño escoge eso pero qué fácil
es para mí juzgar cuando yo tuve una
mamá amorosa abuelitos amorosos un
entorno amoroso con ausencia de papá y
con historias tristes como las que todos
tenemos en la vida pero quién soy yo
para juzgar a un niño que creció en
medio de la violencia en ese momento
entendí wow el dolor ha sido mi gran
maestro porque fue el dolor el que me
hizo que saliera adelante fue el dolor
el que me hizo que no me rindiera fue el
dolor el que me ayudó a ser incansable a
ser resiliente a ser inquebrantable a
seguir ya seguir cuando todos me decían
que no se podía ese dolor fue un regalo
de dios fue un regalo del universo y
cuando hace dos años y medio mi mamá
estaba falleciendo de la enfermedad de
alzheimer
y qué pasó en sus últimos quince días en
la cama y yo la veía el alzheimer se
lanza es una enfermedad muy muy fuerte
muy muy cruel seguramente algunos de
ustedes la han vivido a través de seres
queridos yo la veía que ya estaba
completamente desconectada ya no comía
apenas respiraba con la ayuda estaba en
el dolor del doctor ya me había dicho
que que iba a fallecer porque había ya
dejado de ya no podía tragar porque la
comida el cuerpo se le va olvidando todo
y lo último que se te olvide es la
distinción entre respirar y comer
entonces ya la comida se te va a los
pulmones te da una neumonía y te mueres
o de eso te mueres de hambre en su caso
pues murió de hambre con con morfina y
yo la veía y la veía a veces como en su
mente alucinando todavía las mismas
cosas que le había visto alucinar toda
su vida sus dolores sus mortificación es
que cuando ella estaba en sus cinco
sentidos yo le puedes ir mamita no y le
agarraba la mano y le daba un beso o le
cantábamos el cielito lindo para que se
saliera de ahí pero ya ahí ya no me
escuchaba y yo veía su carita
estaba sufriendo literalmente juntaba
sus cejas y yo conocía esa cara yo
conocía esas expresiones se trataba de
hablar y tuya no la podía yo sacar de
desde ese patrón mental y me acuerdo que
se lo comentaba a mis maestros de la
universidad y me dijeron marco antonio
estás haciendo otra vez lo mismo está
sufriendo sí pero porque está juzgando
una vez más el sufrimiento como algo
malo como sabes si en este momento está
teniendo sus momentos más cercanos de
sufrimiento para poder dejarlo ir como
sabes en el fondo en su consciencia no
está aprendiendo y entendiendo algo como
sabes si no está recibir repasando su
vida y si en ese repaso de su vida en
algún momento va a entender lo mismo que
tú ya has entendido
y como sabe si ese dolor que está
sufriendo no es para que tú también en
tiendas a través de ese dolor como no te
estás regalando este momento para que tú
acabes de aceptar y entender el dolor es
un maestro es un maestro espiritual que
dios te ama también a través del dolor
que se presenta yo dije oh guau es
verdad entonces hice todo lo posible por
respirar por dejarla ir
le tomé sus manitas y le dije todo está
bien todo está bien te quiero te amo
hiciste lo mejor te voy a extrañar pero
vas a estar bien y el momento que por
fin se fue mi corazón se desgarró y la
extraño con todo mi corazón
la extraño todos los días pero a través
de estos dos años y medio de vivir el
duelo de vivir luto de su partida
también con su partida he descubierto
que me dejó otro gran regalo porque como
duele y quienes hemos perdido un ser muy
cercano
sabemos que duele mucho los expertos
dicen que uno puede tardar entre tres y
ocho años o más
y superar esto si no recibes ayuda
profesional pero ese dolor que estoy
sintiendo ahora aprendido no a
rechazarlo ni a revelarme con él sino
decirle ok dolor si en el pasado me
enseñaste otras cosas que me estás
enseñando y solo estado preguntando y
preguntando y la mejor respuesta con la
que con la que he podido vivir es tal
vez ahora ese dolor me está enseñando a
vivir sin la muleta sin el apoyo de
amarme a mí porque soy un buen hijo
porque ya no tengo ese pretexto y
descubrí que yo realmente me quería me
valoraba y me amaba porque yo pensaba
soy un buen hijo y luego entonces valgo
luego entonces merezco amor luego
entonces la gente me quiere luego
entonces soy alguien y su ausencia me
permite entender que valgo aunque yo no
sea un buen hijo ya no puedo ser un buen
hijo que valgo aunque yo no esté
rescatando ni salvando a nadie que valgo
aunque no tenga ningún rol y no esté
siendo el salvador o el apoyo o el o el
héroe de nadie
simplemente el dolor me está enseñando
que valgo simplemente porque soy porque
existo y que merezco amor simplemente
porque existo y que no tengo que hacer
nada para merecer me ese amor luego
entonces también estoy entendiendo que
cada ser humano cada uno de ustedes y
cada una de las personas que viven en
este planeta en este momento merece amor
sin tener que hacer nada para ganárselo
y esa compasión y ese amor que empieza a
sentir hacia mí empieza a reflejarse
hacia los demás así que una vez más el
dolor está siendo mi gran maestro yo los
invito a que cualquier dolor que estén
sintiendo
o que vayan a sentir se acuerden de esta
conversación y en medio de ese remolino
y esa tristeza y esa angustia y esa
ansiedad le digan al dolor ok no es
agradable preferiría no tenerte presente
pero que me estás enseñando si dios te
están mandando si el universo está
mandando sea lo mejor yo también soy co
creador de este o cooperadora de este
dolor qué lección llena de amor me estás
presentando porque si abres tus ojitos y
lo ves con los ojos del corazón vas a
poder encontrar lecciones maravillosas
que pueden transformar tu vida pero si
te cierras y lo resiste sino porque a mí
lo único que va a hacer es hundirte y
hundirte y hundirte más entonces esa es
la opción de todos el dolor puedes verlo
como un castigo como tu enemigo como una
maldición o puedes verlo literalmente
como la manifestación máxima de amor de
dios y del universo que a través de esa
medicina te está enseñando quién eres
cuál es tu misión está enseñando a amar
y amar de una forma incondicional que al
final del día es la esencia de dios y
tal vez solo tal vez esa es la única y
verdadera razón por la que estamos vivos
en este momento muchas gracias y dios
los bendiga
gratis
[Aplausos]
[Música]